ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen euch
allen an einem Mittwoch der geprägt ist
ja von Ausnahme Winterwetter kann man
sagen von wintertief gertrut heftige
Schneefälle und Eisregen sorgen seit den
frühen Morgenstunden für teils extremste
Glätte deutschlandweit und das hat
Auswirkungen auf den gesamten Verkehr
vieler Ort sind die Straßen spiegelgatt
die Winterdienste sind im Dauereinsatz
der Zugverkehr ist eingeschränkt der ja
Flugzeugverkehr ist eingeschränkt hier
sehen wir aktuelle Bilder von heute
morgen und entsprechend rutschig die
ganze Geschichte auch auf den Straßen
auf der A6 kurz vor sarbrücken da
kollidierten mehrere Fahrzeuge
miteinander auch in anderen Orten wie
z.B hier auf der A8 nah der
französischen Grenze kam es zu
zahlreichen Unfällen die Flughäfen
München und Frankfurt äh haben
zahlreiche Flüge gestrichen Landungen
ebenfalls ja und die Schulen und Kita
sind entsprechend ebenfalls heute in
vielen Orten Deutschlands
geschlossen soll es so bleiben oder auch
nicht wann ist der Spuk wieder vorbei
darüber wollen wir heute reden bei ZDF
heute live mit unserer Meteorologin
Katja hornffer und gerne auch mit all
euren Fragen Meinungen und Anliegen die
ihr uns wie immer schicken könnt über
die Kommentarspalten oder via Mail und
gerne könnt auch ihr uns einen Stand der
Dinge schicken mit Fotos mit Videos von
euren Regionen wie schlimm es vielleicht
aktuell bei euch ist den auch das teilen
wir gerne mit der Community hier und
wollen uns mal einen Überblick über
diese gesamte Wetterlage verschaffen und
somit begrüße ich auch unseren heutigen
Gast katja hornffer ist bei mir aus der
ZDF Wetterredaktion grüße Dich Katja
vielen Dank gut hergeschlittert heute ja
mich kein Problem ich weiß ja was auf
mich zukommt und bin entsprechend früh
losgefahren genau wie wir alle
wahrscheinlich das Wetter ist ja schon
mal rutschig im Winter das ist ja nichts
Neues jetzt gab's aber innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit extremsten Eisregen
erklär uns was es da wettermäßig genau
wie passiert dass es jetzt so gefährlich
geworden ist also erstmal hatten wir die
sehr kalte Luft und auch sehr tiefe
Temperaturen jetzt in der Nacht zum Teil
bis -15° Eiseskälte und jetzt ist von
Südwesten dieses schon von dir
angesprochene tief Gertrud herangezogen
übrigens international heißt das Irene
und das hat eben mit dieser milden Luft
viel Regen mitgebracht und dieser Regen
ist in den in die eiskalte Luft
reingefallen wir können uns dazu auch
was anschauen da sieht man das nämlich
sehr schön auf dieser Matz wie eben die
warme Luft aufgleitet man sieht auch
wenn diese Kaltluftschicht besonders
breit ist besonders massiv ist dann kann
tatsächlich aus den Wolken noch
Schneekristalle rauskommen und dann
Schneid es auch heftig genau das sehen
wir wir haben also eine Gleichzeitigkeit
von kräftigen Schneefällen von
Glatteisregen und auch von Regen wir
sehen hier sehr schön wieer einfach die
milde Luft aufgleitet die Kälte bleibt
noch bestehen es braucht also richtig
viel Dampf in Anführungsstrichen sehr
viel Kraft das dann irgendwann auch
diese kalte Luft weggeräumt werden kann
das passiert aber gar nicht denn wir
haben es mit zwei verschiedenen Tiefs zu
tun ein Tief hält einfach komplett
dagegen und das wird bedeuten dass
morgen spätestens dann die kalte Luft
wieder zurückzieht und damit der Regen
weg ist und wir wieder nur noch Schnee
haben mm also ein paar Stunden müssen
wir sozusagen noch durchhalten viele
Stunden viele Stunden noch und das
Erstaunliche ist ja dass das auch dann
so konzentriert ist wir können uns das
hier mal anschauen wir sind bei heute.de
das haben wir uns aufgemacht da findet
ihr übrigens immer alle aktuellen Infos
auch in eurer Region und da gibt's hier
diese
Deutschlandkarte und da sehen wir ja
hier dieser Bereich lila das ist ja
aktuell der extremste wetterpunkt ne
während der Norden im gelb gefühlt wie
unangetastet ist oder wie kann man das
Deuten K ja ganz genau also diese das
sind einfach die Unwetterwarnung des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes die schon seit
gestern gut vorhergesehen haben wo es
diesen ganz gefährlichen Glatteisregen
gibt das ist diese lila Region da
erwarten wir zum Teil 10 20 lit Regen
pro Quadratmeter alles als Eisregen und
du kannst dir vorstellen was dann
passiert dann gibt es Eispanzer nicht
nur auf dem Boden sondern auch auf
Gegenständen auf Kränen auf Zäunen auf
Gerüsten auf Bäumen also das wird alles
total gefährlich und drumrum gibt's auch
Eisregen aber nicht ganz so viel und
nördlich von diesem lila Gebiet da fällt
kräftige Schnee und in Norddeutschland
vollkommen richtig ist die Lage komplett
entspannt da sind wir noch voll in der
Kaltluft drin Temperaturen leicht über
0° zum Teil vielleicht sogar mal heute
ein sonnens ein kleiner Schneeschauer da
kriegt man von dem all dem gar nichts
mit liegt einfach daran dass wir so ein
Kampf der Giganten haben sozusagen zwei
tief das eine schaufelt die kalte Luft
von Norden heran und das andere kommt
mit viel Regen dagegen wir haben dazu
später dann ja auch noch einen Film wo
wir das ganz gut sehen können das ist
einfach wir nach wie vor heute den
ganzen Tag über noch mit diesem sehr
gefährlichen Glatteisregen zu tun haben
die Unwetterwarnung die wir gerade
gesehen haben vom Deutschen Wetterdienst
die laufen zum Teil bis morgen früh 4
Uhr das heißt also wer jetzt noch denkt
ah ich kom heute Nachmittag gut nach
Hause in diesem in dieser Region in
dieser lila eingefärbten Region der kann
das eigentlich wahrscheinlich ziemlich
gut vergessen mm Stichwort heute du hast
uns auch eine aktuelle Wettervorschau
mitgebracht das können wir uns
vielleicht auch mal ganz kurz
anschauen ja was uns heute an diesem
besonderen wettermittwoch so erwartet es
ist glatt vor allem und da sehen wir
dieses Gebiet genau hier seeht wir sehen
wir sehr schön diese beiden Tiefs die
ich angesprochen habe also gertrrid auf
der einen Seite und farima auf der
anderen Seite wir sehen wie farima die
kalte Luft von Nordwesten herantreibt
und gleichzeitig das Tief Gertrud bis
morgen Abend einmal über den Süden
Deutschlands hin wegzieht rosa
eingefärbt das ist der Schnee und was
wir hier ganz schön sehen ist dass es da
eine scharfe Grenze gibt wir sprechen
von einer Luftmassengrenze und wir sehen
dass am Anfang alles von Südwesten
heranschwappt und dann morgen übertag
schwappt es dann Richtung Südosten
wieder raus und aus dem Regen wird
wieder mehr Schnee das heißt die
brisanteste Wetterlage ist eigentlich
heute Nachmittag mit diesem ganz
gefährlichen andauernden glattweißregen
der über einen ganz breiten Streifen
geht also es geht vom Saarland über
Rheinlandpfalz über Hessen bis nach
Bayern und erst in der Nacht entspannt
sich das langsam wenn eben die kalte
Luft dann doch gewinnt langsam und dann
als schneemorgen das ganze Gebiet dann
aus Deutschland raus diese Karte hat ja
auch gerade ganz gut gezeigt das wollte
ich dich nämlich als nächstes Fragen ist
jetzt Deutschland das einzige Land wo
sich das so konzentriert hat
wahrscheinlich nicht wir haben gerade
Europa gesehen und das Gebiet zieht ja
auch schon durch Mitteleuropa komplett
durch kann man sagen also vor allen
Dingen Frankreich kann man da erwähnen
da gibt's natürlich genau solche
Behinderungen auch in den alten Ländern
selbstverständlich mhm uns erreichen
schon die ersten zuschauermeldungen
servus aus dem vereisten Regensburg
schreibt uns John hier regnet es und
alles friert s vort zu einer dicken
Eisplatte ist schon krass gerade bei uns
schreibt er uns also es ist allerhand
los in Deutschland danke schön für euer
Feedback und gerne jederzeit über die
kommentarschalten oder wieer me könnt
ihr uns ein Update von E schicken und ja
da sind wir dann mal gespannt wie es so
ausschaut die Karte heute hast du uns
auch noch mitgebracht da können wir noch
mal speziell
ja auf Deutschland schauen genau hier
sehen wir erstmal den vorschaufilm für
heute Nachmittag das geht bis 19 Uhr ich
habe hier mal mit diesem warnreiecken ah
das hier ist jetzt schon die Nacht da
sieht man dass dieser Bereich mit dem
Glatteisregen dünner wird deswegen habe
ich kleinere
warnreiecke genommen hier sieht man noch
mal heute Nachmittag viel Glatteisregen
aber die Böden sind ja gefroren und das
heißt es bleibt einfach glatt weiß ist
jetzt hier der Schnee wir sehen dass es
in der Nacht kräftig weiterschneid und
das gilt eben nicht nur für Bergregionen
sondern auch fürs Flachland da sind
betroffen das südliche
Nordrhein-Westfalen Hessen Thüringen
auch Teile von SachsenAnhalt und von
Sachsen wir sprechen von 10 20 in
einigen Regionen 30 oder 40 cm Neuschnee
und das ist auch was was nicht alle Tage
vorkommt dass es auch im Flachland so
viel schneiden kann dazu kann man noch
erklären dass gerade bei Temperaturen um
null 0 Grad die Schneeflocken besonders
groß werden weil dann eben noch ein
bisschen feuchte Phase also bisschen
Regen mit untergemischt wird und dann
können das besonders große Flocken
werden und dann gibt es halt diese enorm
großen Schneemengen also auch das ist
eine Gefahr nicht nur der Glatteisregen
sondern auch der Schneefall und unsere
Zuschauer interessiert was diese
Schneemengen alles anrichten können
Stefan leibach fragt kann es zu
Stromausfällen kommen durch Umstürze von
Hochspannungsmasten und Leitungen durch
diesen Eisregen kann da irgendwas
knicken brechen ja natürlich also wenn
wir uns vorstellen dass über Stunden und
wir besprechen jetzt von mindestens den
nächsten 6ch Stunden vielleicht auch den
nächsten 10 Stunden ganz genau wissen
wir es nicht aber wenn wir uns
vorstellen dass über Stunden dieser
Eisregen kommt und das sind große Mengen
20 30 l pro quadratm wenn das als
Eisregen runterkommt können wir uns die
Panzer vorstellen die sich da auf
Strommasten ablagern können und
natürlich keine Ahnung wie stabil so ein
Strommast ist ich würde mal davon
ausgehen dass wir heute da noch Meldung
leider kriegen werden das Kräne das
Strommasten und so weiter Umknicken und
deswegen auch die ganz dringende Warnung
nicht in Wälder zu gehen weil das
natürlich auch für Bäume gilt ja auch
die haben dann unter der Eislast unter
der Schneelast zu leiden und können dann
auch umkippen also es ist
brandgefährlich ich würde sowieso jedem
empfehlen möglichst nicht rauszugehen
bei diesem Wetter derer kann im
Homeoffice bleiben oder auch privat zu
Hause bleiben ich weiß nicht ob du das
auch in Zahlen ob es da Zahlen gibt
Katja Zini fragt wie viel Schnee ist
denn zu erwarten und wie lange bleibt
der liegen also kann man sagen P mal
Daum so und so viele Massen an Schnee
kommen da heute runter ja genau also in
diesem Bereich den haben wir jetzt eben
auf der einen Vorschau auch ganz gut
gesehen in der Mitte Deutschlands da
können das 10 bis 20 bis morgen
vielleicht sogar 30 bis 40 cm Schnee
sein und da es ja insgesamt wieder
kälter wird bleibt der dann auch erstmal
liegen die Böden sind ja immer noch sehr
kalt also das ist eine ganze Menge
bleibt auch erstmal liegen und ähm
anders sieht das natürlich in
Süddeutschland aus da ist ja diese
markant milde Luft herangekommen also am
oberrein da erwarten wir heute
Nachmittag Temperaturen deutlich über
10° das natürlich klar da bleibt dann
kein Schnee liegen das ist übrigens auch
noch eine ganz interessante Sache was
man heute ganz gut sehen konnte dass ja
die milde Luft sich über die Kälte am
Boden schiebt deswegen hat es im
Schwarzwald weit oben den Regen gegeben
aber unten am oberrehein den
Glatteisregen wir hatten ja Meldung aus
Freiburg und so weiter da war es einfach
noch kalt genug diese kalte Grundschicht
die dafür gesorgt da den Glatteisregen
gab danke schön Katja erstmal bis hier
hin wir reden gleich noch weiter wollen
jetzt aber mal raus ins Land schalten zu
unseren Reporterinnen und Reportern die
natürlich das Wettergeschehen gerade in
den ganz extremen Gebieten mitverfolgt
haben das Saarland ist ja eine der
Regionen gewesen wo es sich aktuell auch
noch immer konzentriert und in
Saarbrücken auf der alten Brücke steht
meine Kollegin Claudia Oberst für uns
ich grüße dich Claudia erzähl uns wie
schlimm hat diese Glätte euch heute
erwischt im
Saarland ja hallo nach Mainz ja also das
war heute morgen wirklich ein ziemlich
böses Erwachen für viele Leute das kann
man so sagen also es hat heute morgen
schon sehr früh dann angefangen zu
regnen erstmal nur ganz leicht so ein
bisschen Nieselregen und wie du sehen
kannst legt es jetzt noch mal richtig
nach und wir waren heute morgen auch
schon ein bisschen in der Stadt
unterwegs und haben mit den Menschen
gesprochen und es ist so ein Mann hat
uns z.B erzählt dass er erstmal gar
nicht bis zu seiner Garage
Entschuldigung erstmal gar nicht bis zu
seiner Garage gekommen ist von seinem
Haus aus weil eben der Weg glatt war ein
anderer hat uns erzählt dass er sich
wirklich an der an seinem Haus an der
Kante entlang gehangelt hat um irgendwie
vorwärts zu kommen ich kann das nur
bestätigen also ich bin heute morgen
auch hier wirklich auf dem Gehweg ganz
schön geschlittert und das Problem ist
eben auch dass diese Eisschicht nicht
nur auf dem Boden liegt sondern die
liegt z.B halt auch auf Mülltonnen drauf
oder auch auf dem Geländer drauf und ich
kann das jetzt gerne mal hier zeigen wir
stehen ja auf einer Brücke wenn ich hier
einmal runter
guckt also man sieht vielleicht wie
meine Hand
da
drüber gleitet sozusagen das heißt man
hat also auch am Geländer erstmal nicht
wirklich einen guten Griff und das macht
es super schwierig und wir haben auch
ein Mädchen getroffen heute morgen die
schon erzählt hat dass sie eben schon
hingefallen ist einfach weil dieses
Glatteis so gefährlich ist umso
erstaunlicher dass ich da noch manche
ins Auto überhaupt rein audia kannst du
uns was zur Straßenlage erzählen wir
sehen ja im Hintergrund bei dir fahren
etliche auf den Straßen trotz dieses
Wetters wie schlimm war die Verkehrslage
heute
früh ja also hier hinter mir seht ihr
die Stadtautobahn von sarbrücken die ist
also heute morgen auch schon früh
gestreut worden da fließt der Verkehr
auch ganz gut das kann man ja sehen da
ist keine Gefahr das Problem hier auf
den Straßen ist mehr natürlich einmal in
den Wohngebieten gerade auch hier in
salbrücken haben wir ein pa paar
Wohngebiete z.B an an Hängen an kleinen
Bergen da ist es dann so dass die Leute
teilweise nicht aus dem Haus kommen bzw
nicht den Berg runterkommen
und dann das zweite Problem ist
natürlich außerhalb der Orte dann das
sind die Autobahn also das ist wirklich
hier im Saarland hat's auch heute morgen
besonders zwei schlimme Unfälle gegeben
das war einmal die A6 rüber nach
Mannheim wo dann also es so schlimm war
durch diese Eisschicht auf der Fahrbahn
dass mehrere Autos kollidiert sind dass
die Fahrbahn
dann auch
geschlossen werden musste also die
Strecke die Polizei hat mir jetzt vor
ein paar Minuten gesagt dass sie die
Unfallstelle soweit geräumt haben und
dass die Autos jetzt auch wieder
Richtung Mannheim fahren können also die
Spur ist frei und dann heute morgen gab
es das auch
in die andere Richtung rüber auf der A8
bei märzig hier ganz im Westen vom
Saarland da gab es auch so einen großen
Unfall also das ist einfach wirklich
super gefährlich ähm und dann was jetzt
noch hinzu kommt hier auch im Saarland
ist wir sind ja hier an der Grenze zu
Frankreich und Luxemburg da dürfen ja
aktuell keine LKW
auf den Straßen fahren weshalb
es sich jetzt an der Grenze zu Luxemburg
ähm lkwstau sozusagen bildet die Fahrer
wissen halt nicht wohin und stellen sich
dann da mal auf den Seitenstreifen und
warten halt mal ab wann sie dann
weiterfahren können und auch da hat uns
eben der Polizeisprecher hier gesagt da
ist die Polizei Vorort und versucht eben
die Gefahrenlage so gut es geht zu
minimieren damit da eben keine Unfälle
passieren D dass keine Menschen
irgendwie verletzt werden hat jetzt auch
schon gut die Frage von unserem
Zuschauer John beantwortet der auch sich
nach den Unfällen erkundigen wollte die
es heute im saarand gab Claudia noch
ganz kurz die es soll ja noch ein paar
Stunden jetzt gehen bis morgen hat uns
Katja hornifer gerade erzählt wie blickt
man dann auf die nächsten Stunden im
Saarland Schulen Kitas bleiben die
weiterhin geschlossen
ja also heute ist es ja so dass
es teilweise sind die Schulen
geschlossen die kitaitas ja auch manche
haben geöffnet es ist aber so dass hat
die Bildungsministerin ja gestern schon
angekündigt dass die Eltern selbst
entscheiden können ob sie die Kinder in
die Schule schicken oder nicht also
heute bleibt auf jeden Fall einiges zu
auch z.B freibeder
Bibliotheken Bürgerämter solche
Einrichtungen
oder Bürgeramt hat vielleicht dannen
Notdienst also es ist wirklich so man
kann sagen dass das Leben hier gerade so
ein bisschen erstarrt ist wenn man die
metaper des Eises aufgreifen will und
die Leute hier bleiben so gut es geht zu
Hause im Homeoffice versuchen die
Termine auch zu verschieben und wir alle
warten eigentlich daruf dass es dann
hoffentlich morgen morgen früh morgen
Vormittag dann wieder besser wird und
soweit Normalität einkehrt ja bis dahin
Claudia kommt bitte auch wieder sicher
zurück ins Studio danke schön für diese
Einschätzungen Claudia Oberst live aus
sbrücken war das und wir schalten direkt
weiter zu unserem Reporter Andreas linke
er ist für uns in Baden-Württemberg und
wollen uns auch bei ihm mal erkundigen
nach der Lage Süddeutschland war ja
heute im Fokus dieses ähm enormen
Winterwetters
Andreas ich grüße dich erzähl uns wie
ist die Lage bei euch ähnlich
Ausnahmezustand wie im
Saarland also auf jeden Fall regnet der
angekündigte Regen ist da
ähm in den unterschiedlichen Regionen
von Baden-Württemberg hat das dann
unterschiedliche Auswirkungen
tatsächlich können wir sagen dass im
badischen Raum also in der Rheinschiene
Richtung Saarland was wir eben da gerade
gehört haben dass da die Auswirkungen
größer sind als in vielen anderen Teilen
badenwürttembergs ähm dort ist auch die
A5 die Autobahn gesperrt wegen
glatteisunfällen und um auch die Straße
da wieder frei zu bekommen ähnliche
Situation also wie wir eben gerade aus
dem sain gehört haben andererseits sind
viele andere Regionen in
baden-württenemberg gar nicht so schlimm
betroffen also da hier hercht nicht das
Chaos z.B auch hier in Stuttgart wo wir
jetzt hier sind also wenn man sich hier
umschaut hier herrscht ganz normaler
Berufsverkehr das ist auch das was wir
heute morgen wir haben an der gleichen
Stelle um 9R schon mal eine schalte
gemacht für die heute Nachrichten auch
gesehen haben also es wurde ein bisschen
vorsichtiger gefahren es wurde weniger
gefahren aber es war in Stuttgart alles
unterwegs wir können jetzt auch mal auf
den Boden gucken vorhin war hier noch
eine kleine Eisschicht neben der Straße
das ist auch alles jetzt hier weggetaut
also es sind viele Regionen in denen
nichts war die Eisschicht auch markant
war vorhin hier an dieser Stelle wenige
Meter daneben hatten die
Straßenmeistereien hier so gut
vorgesorgt dass hier auch kein Eis mehr
war das ist glaube ich etwas was viele
heute hier in Stuttgart und in der
anderen Regionen von Baden-Württemberg
die nicht so nah Richtung Saarland
liegen erlebt haben also man war
vorsichtig es gab Homeoffice aber auch
viele waren gar nicht so Ark betroffen
ich selber bin auch Primer mit dem
Fahrrad ins Büro gekommen heute sehr
mutig aber das war auch schon meine
nächste Frage Andreas die Winter waren
die gut vorbereitet bei
euch ja die waren gut vorbereitet also
es hatte ja auch die einringlichen
Warnung gegeben ich glaube es war diese
Mischung viel Vorsicht bei den
Menschen gute Vorbereitung bei den
Winterdiensten und eben in einigen
Regionen war es dann gar nicht so
schlimm wie vorher gesagt wie das
weitergeht wissen wir noch nicht Moment
sind ganz warme Temperaturen diese
Gefahr ist ja im Laufe des Tages noch
nicht vorüber auch die Behörden waren
vor zu viel Leichtsinn in diesen
Momenten aber im Moment muss man sagen
kann man sich ganz entspannt bewegen
zumindest in den Großstädten so wie hier
in Stuttgart sagt Andreas linke aus
badenwürtenberg Andreas ich danke dir
und auch dir einen sicheren
nachhauseg ja Katja warme Temperaturen
du hast gerade schon genickt mit einem
Grinsen das ist hatten gerade auch schon
die Karte eingeblendet die noch mal
zeigt wie es aktuell ist und da ist
Stuttgart eben komplett raus da ist die
Milderung schon voll da da erwarten wir
heute Nachmittag Temperaturen 2 bis 11°
da sieht man da steht Andreas linke
komplett im Regen und fragt sich was
stellen die sich denn so an denn weiter
im Norden gibt's halt den Glatteisregen
man sieht das hier noch mal ganz gut
welche Region so betroffen ist also
Saarland südliches rinland-pfalz dann
Hessen nördliches Baden-Württemberg und
große Teile von Bayern bis hinüber nach
Thüringen dann dieser Streifen gelb
schraffiert im Norden der sich mit
Schnee dann an
schließt und ganz im Norden Deutschlands
da kriegt man von dem ganzen gar nichts
mit wie schon gesagt also ein paar
schöne Momente da sogar mit Sonnenschein
und einige schneeschau über der Küste
also ist komplett unterschiedlich wo man
sich gerade aufhält in Deutschland wie
muss man den Temperaturen allgemein
bewerten ich kenn es ja von mir selber
wenn das alles was im Plusbereich ist
denke ich auch kannst du einfach ohne
Probleme rausgehen aber wahrscheinlich
trückt der Schein weil der Boden ja
weiterhin erstmal noch kälter ist als
die Lufttemperatur ne das trügt also wir
sagen sogar wenn es eine Nachttemperatur
von 3° gibt dann ist nicht
ausgeschlossen das am Boden Frost gibt
also immer dann sagen wir schon hier
aufpassen könnte irgendwie glatt sein
und wenn natürlich wir eine
Vorgeschichte haben also wenn es vorher
schon sehr lange sehr eisig war und wir
erinnern uns haben ja Leute sind ja
Leute Schlittschuh gelaufen no über
fluteten Wiesen und so weiter dann
dauert das natürlich bis der Frost so
langsam rauszieht aus dem Boden also da
muss man aufpassen mhm noch mal die
Frage wie lange bleibt es jetzt so glatt
du hast es vorhin schon gesagt für
Zuschauer die gerade dazu gekommen sind
wie lange müssen wir uns auf diese
extreme Glätte einstellen also heute den
ganzen Nachmittag über gibt's noch
diesen Glatteisregen genauso in diesem
Streifen den wir vorhin schon gesehen
haben also ich wiederhole das gerne noch
mal Saarland rheinlandfalz Hessen Bayern
bis hinüber nach Thüringen nördlich
davon da fällt der kräftige Schnee da
sind 10 bis 20 zum Teil sogar 30 bis 40
cm Schnee zu erwarten und das eben nicht
nur in den Bergen sondern auch im
Flachland von Südwesten wird's jetzt
markant milder im Süden
Baden-Württembergs haben wir das gemerkt
Temperaturen bis 11° heute Nachmittag
aber das das ist nicht von langer Dauer
denn morgen gewinnt dann schon die kalte
Luft und das bedeutet dass es von Norden
wieder kälter wird und dass dieser
Schnee die wir da gesehen haben über der
Mitte Deutschlands der zieht dann
langsam weiter südwärts und dann ist es
nicht mehr so gefährlich durch Eisregen
denn das Problem bei dem Eisregen ist ja
wenn die milde Luft über diese
Eiseskälte
zieht und dann wir so ein Eispanzer
kriegen das wird sich dann mehr und mehr
auflösen wobei wenn der Boden noch
gefroren ist und wir haben da erstmal
Glätte dann ist das auch nicht sofort
weg bei diesen Mengen die da runter
kommen ja wenn wir da den 2 cm dicke
Eisschicht haben die muss dann auch
erstmal wegtauen ich habe ja gesagt im
Süden BadenWürttemberg ist es zwar mild
geworden sonst aber bleibt es zum Teil
bei Temperaturen nur knapp über 0° und
wenn dann der Schnee da drauf kommt ist
das auch noch immer gefährlich auch
morgen noch danke schön erstmal Katja
für diese Einschätzungen wir jetzt muss
ich gleich noch mal nachfragen hatten
eigentlich auch noch einen Kollegen
stehen am Flughafen und er ist jetzt
mittlerweile da danke schön für die Info
Markus wollsiffer denn auch in Frankfurt
gab es heute Ausnahmezustand zahlreiche
Flüge und STS und Landungen wurden dort
gestrichen deswegen schalten wir mal
rüber zu dir Markus erzähl uns wie ist
die Lage bei
Dir ja ein außergewöhnlicher Tag in der
Tat heute am Deutschlands größten
Airport wir sind hier an der
Enteisungsanlage also diese Fahrzeuge im
Hintergrund die haben bis vor wenigen
Minuten noch ganz kräftig
ist sozusagen im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes unter Hochdruck das ist natürlich
ganz wichtig dass zumindest einige
Flugzeuge hier abheben können und wir
sehen es auf der anderen Seite das ist
die Flotte der Winterdienst hier am
Frankfurter Flughafen die Leisten heute
außergewöhnliches die Männer und Frauen
die sind ja fast rund um die Uhr im
Einsatz bereits heute Nacht wurde
angefangen mit der Enteisung man muss
sich vergegenwärtigen 1,7 Millionen
Liter Enteisungsmittel die reichen bei
Vollbetrieb gerade einmal 5 Tage das
zeigt natürlich auch die Ausmaße wir
kommen gerade aus Terminal 1 Halle A
Frankfurter Flughafen da war jetzt kein
Chaos ausgebrochen aber natürlich viel
Frust bei den Reisenden insgesamt aber
da überwiegt das Verständnis die
Sicherheit die geht ja vor der große
Appell des Airports aber auch der
Fluggesellschaften war wer weiß dass
sein Flug schon vorher ausfällt der soll
erst gar nicht zum Flughafen kommen man
kann zu Hause viel leichter umbuchen das
nervt natürlich aber immerhin hat man
etwas Planungssicherheit wenn man weiß
wann dann doch vielleicht der nächste
Flug geht morgen übermorgen vielleicht
mhm das wäre direkt meine nächste Frage
Markus
wann plant man denn seitens des
Flughafens wieder Normalbetrieb
einzuführen wurde da schon irgendwas
kommuniziert das ist im Moment eine Art
auf Sicht fahren also wir hatten Kontakt
mit Fraport dem Flughafenbetreiber mit
der lufthanser aber auch mit der
Deutschen Flugsicherung in langen und da
heißt es es sind viele Rädchen die
ineinander greifen müssen das kann man
adck so nicht sagen heute wären über
1000 Staats und Landungen geplant 5 600
sind bereits abgesagt bereits als die
Unwetterwarnungen gestern bekannt wurden
insofern da hat man sich darauf
eingerichtet natürlich manche die können
nicht vermeiden hier in den Flughafen zu
kommen alle die den Frankfurter
Flughafen ja als Durchgangsstation
nutzen viele Reisen ja Richtung USA über
den Atlantik oder Richtung Asien also da
ist der Frankfurter Flughafen ja ein
wichtiges Drehkreuz und für diese
Reisenden da hat Fraport angekündigt ja
da werden tatsächlich auch Feldbetten
aufgestellt da soll eine gewisse
Versorgung geleistet werden das sind ja
meistens auch mehrere Stunden die man
dann ausharen muss ja und je nach Alin
gibt es vereinzelt auch Hotelkontingente
also es ist im Moment eine schwierige
Situation kein Chaos aber angespannt das
System Flughafen das steht heute unter
besonderer Beobachtung absolut aber wir
haben es ja gerade auch bei dir gesehen
die der Winterdienst ist ja mit großem
Aufgebot da neben dir da das heißt wenn
es die nächsten Stunden so bleiben
sollte ist man vom Flughafen her oder
seitens das Flughafens halbwegs gut
vorbereitet auf dieses
Wetter ja tatsächlich also man macht
alles möglich aber bis der Regelbetrieb
wieder starten kann da müssen viele
Faktoren stimmen einerseits die
Flugzeuge müssen enteist werden klar
andererseits muss alles geräumt und
gestreut werden das sind ja riesige
Flächen hier im Frankfurter Flughafen
und bis der Regelbetrieb starten kann
das haben wir heute gelernt da müssen
aufwendige Tests gemacht werden also im
Grunde Testfahrten wie viel Gripp haben
die Reifen hier auf dem Asphalt und ein
ein Reibungskoeffizient der ist da
entscheidend eine physikalische Größe
wie wir heute gelernt haben erst wenn
der funktioniert dann ist wieder an
einen Regelbetrieb zu denken das kann
leider noch ein bisschen dauern wir
haben es eben von Katja horonneffer
gehört das ist eine schwierige Situation
aber wir hoffen alle so Richtung
Wochenende dass dann wieder
Normalbetrieb herrscht Einschätzungen
live vom Frankfurter Flughafen von
Markus wulsffer Markus danke dir und
auch ein sicheres nach Hause
kommen ja Katja mit dem Grip das ist so
eine Sache das kann man beim Flughafen
vielleicht testen als Autofahrer er
schwierig auf jeden Fall sollte man das
tun denn wenn man losfährt dann kann man
ja sofort mal ganz kurz ein kleinen
Bremstest machen dann weiß man was einen
erwartet wenn man überhaupt losfd wie
gesagt am besten lieber stehen lassen
das Auto zuletzt wollte ich dich noch
mal auf die Empfehlungen seitens das das
für Zuschauer wir haben schon gehört
besser zu Hause bleiben kann man morgen
rausgehen ja nein ja also erstmal ist es
natürlich nicht ganz Deutschland
betroffen wir haben schon darüber
gesprochen in Norddeutschland fragt man
sich was stellen die sich da so an und
auch im Süden Baden-Württenberg stellt
man sich im Moment schon die Frage was
stellen die sich so an ist doch nur
Regen aber in diesem großen breiten
Streifen und eine solche Lage so große
Regionen betroffen und über einen so
langen Zeitraum das hatten wir zuletzt
wohl 1977 ist also sehr lange her nur
die älteren von uns erinnern sich daran
also das heißt morgen kann man natürlich
schon wieder planen denn morgen zieht
der Schnee ja dann langsam südostwärts
aus Deutschland raus dann ist es mit der
Glätte nicht mehr so ein Problem weil
dann einfach viel Schnee fällt der dann
aber abzieht und dann beruhigt sich die
Lage und wir können dann sagen so ab
Freitag Samstag Sonntag sind das
deutlich ruhigere wettertage also dann
sind wir das wirklich los eine gute
Sache hat dieses Wetter das berichten
heute auch zahlreiche Agenturen dass ich
die Wintersportgebiete in Deutschland
sehr gefreut haben über dieses Wetter
und die Wintersportler fleißig unterwegs
sind vielleicht ein kleiner positiver
Aspekt von diesem ganzen Chaos katja
hornifer war das aus der Wetterredaktion
ich danke dir Katja für das ja für die
Expertise und deine Tipps und danke auch
euch für die Kommentare und alle
Einschätzungen das war ZF heute live und
euch ja einen rutschfreien hoffentlich
Mittwoch und bis
bald